so there's a nice simple setup they give
you a binomial it's worth pointing out
this binomial there's a bit gross
looking you've got numbers in these
coefficients you've gone next squared
you've got our a 1 over X and X to the
negative 1 if you like and then this is
one of those tires where they'll supply
a value for X and if you know that that
you can work out not just the greatest
coefficient but the greatest term now
it's that distinction that we really
want to nail down so I'm going to try
and make it as clear as possible and
just re-emphasize to you that these
objects are different in how they are
different okay so let's begin it under
find the greatest coefficient or the
greatest term you need to know what each
individual term looks like so you can
compare them in some way ok so where I
always begin is by writing the general
term okay
now almost regardless of whether the
question is a coefficient or a term
question I will ask for or I will write
down the general term first because as
you'll see in a couple of minutes and as
you actually know the greatest
coefficient is part of the coefficient
is part of the term so if you can write
down the whole term you will also have
the coefficient and in this case I'm
asking you for both so therefore we
might as well start with this guy okay
so every term in this expansion is going
to have three components you sick of
hearing this yet there's going to be the
binomial coefficient there'll be some
number of what are the other two objects
some number of the two x Squared's right
and some number of the three all X's
okay you'll either have more or less of
these and they will balance out as you
progress through the expansion okay so
let's write those three pieces the first
one will be the binomial coefficient if
this is the general term it's going to
be the kaif term but what will the top
of the of the binomial coefficient be in
this case it's going to be our 10 very
good and I get that from the power now
just one really really minor note and a
few have you been doing this but I even
caught myself to you which is why I
think it's worth an extra reminder
you're going to be writing lots of k's
in this topic and it's not the only
topic it comes up a little bit in
exponential growth and decay as well we
frequently use k
I'm going to encourage you just watch
we're going to encourage you to write
your K in a very particular way I'm
gonna encourage you to write it as one
line and then a second line or bent line
thing okay here is why if you are lazy
and you write your case in one motion
like this you kind of go like this right
and like that that's sort of okay okay
but if you're writing smaller and faster
and under pressure your K in one version
very quickly turns into this which kind
of turns into that which turns into that
and you're like wait well what letter
was that guess what you have ends flying
around here as well as case and you
don't want to be that person some of you
are in this room already who miss reads
your own working and as a consequence
gets the wrong answer okay so the way to
get out of that is to write your case
probably divide do a second thing now
you recognize that letter okay all right
says the binomial coefficient there will
be some number of these things and there
will also be some number of these things
now I pause before I put the number of
those things because at this point you
have a choice don't you okay
one of these is going to be climbing up
and once we climbing down yeah question
yeah I'm not doing that because there's
no why isn't this yeah
part two okay so when we think about
this just pause before we actually write
it down don't write this down just think
about it do you think it matters
ultimately do you think it matters
whether I put K here and 10 minus K here
as compared to where there I put K here
and 10 minus K here do you think it
ultimately matters it shouldn't matter
because if I can put either they should
give me the same expansion in the end
right the difference will be you know
say for example the first term okay we
know the binomial coefficient will
always start with one right if we
started with the K here then when K
equals zero which is the first time I'm
going to write down okay how many of
these guys do I have none so you'll have
ten of eight
right 10-0 so your first term will be 1
times 3 on X to the power of 10 that'll
be your first term and then you'll write
all of the way to the end okay now if I
chose the other way round and chose on
to make this one the K all right well
then you're the first term that you will
write down will not be 10 of these guys
it'll be 10 of this guy but then you
will climb down and you'll end where the
previous ones died it so you'll get the
same thing okay
now I'm going to ask that question again
if we know that ultimately it doesn't
matter and I can choose either of them
is there one that you might prefer hmm
any any takers who likes the orange one
anyone that's not with the K here the 10
mode is killing' okay who like me yeah
I've see some hits who likes the blue
one okay more people who has no opinion
you're like they look the same to me
okay all right sure it's okay to have no
opinion and it's okay to like you know
whichever one you want I'm just going to
put a vote in for going with this one
okay
now you will get the same answer out in
fact the first time I did this question
I did it the other way around okay now
why might we what might we prefer this
one okay it's just a thing to try and
avoid see the mistakes this power here
is simpler do you agree
K is simpler than 10 minus K 10 minus K
it's easier to screw up okay so see
where that minus sign in there but what
the K is going to interact with is this
guy now that has a negative power do you
see that that's X to the negative 1 so
I'm just going to try and avoid having
like negatives playing with each other
if I possibly can okay
but whichever way you do it and I invite
you if you want you know you don't have
to write it the way I'm about to me
whichever way you choose we are going to
arrive at the same answer at the end and
that's one of the lovely things about
this so this is the general term now
what I want to pull out of here is the
coefficient right so you can see these
numbers the twos and the threes they're
going to interact with the binomial
coefficient but I want to get those X's
out of the way okay does that make sense
so let's now carefully break this apart
into a few more pieces here's the
binomial coefficient we'll just leave it
there for now
the - I want that bit the x-squared I
want to separate that bit out
okay so I'm gonna have this many twos
and I'm gonna have this many X Squared's
because they come from the same
extension then over here I'm gonna have
this many threes and I'm gonna take this
opportunity to write because I'm gonna
get these two put together in a second
I'm gonna write the next thing not as a
fraction but with a negative index okay
so I'm gonna write it as X to the
negative K very good there's a negative
one and then there's okay happy times
okay
so at this point I'm now going to gather
all my coefficient together cuz I'm
leaning towards that part of the
question and that will leave this number
here dancing with this number here and
this number here those are all of the
numbers okay the numerical part of this
and now here come our pruning rule so x
squared ^ that that X that's X to the
twenty minus two K xx minus two K I
think you've got another minus K hang it
up here so what will the ultimate power
of X be xx minus 3k
tada okay now at this point here this is
a process you need to become pretty
comfortable with because you don't just
use this particular method these steps
you don't just use them to solve the
greatest coefficient or the greatest
term another question which you were
much more frequently encounter
especially the HSC level is find the
term with a coefficient sorry
find the term which has an X ^ and then
they'll give you a power like say X to
the power 14 okay if you want to be X to
the 14th erm have a look what would you
want this to be what would you do with K
yeah you want 20 minus 6 to get 14 so
you would say K equals 2 right and now
you can evaluate that knopf you go right
so this is a process that is worth
investing in you need to do that
carefully so at this point I've got the
general term okay you've already seen
before mrs. leases mentioned that we use
the capital T to indicate the whole
theme the term and then we will either
use a C for coefficient or a little T
because it's just it's just a part of it
to indicate the coefficient part that
we're interested in so you can see I can
read that off from here it's just all
the stuff that's not X's does that make
sense so I'm gonna do that right now
okay now if this is a part that you have
struggled with before I want you to like
take another color out or a highlighter
or something with that and highlight for
yourself right now if you are finding
the greatest term you are dealing with
this guy right if you're finding the
greatest coefficient you are dealing
with this guy and they are related
clearly but they are significantly
different objects okay